tester la question prêt à se rendre
à Dieu qu'est-il arrivé à Mueller
le mauler buveur de première classe joueurs
quelques visiteurs parmi nous ici aujourd'hui nous
étions au service avec votre
pasteur je n'ai pas vu ces hommes depuis des
décennies ils représentent une période canine
parce que  de mon fils je suis venu ici j'ai trouvé que
vous alliez être enterrés à Arlington et je
me demandais si vous pouviez venir
avec moi je ramène Larry à la maison je pensais que
nous allions à un enterrement nous allons
à un enterrement
ce que vous allez faire sangle  le cercueil sur
le toit de votre voiture nous pourrions faire ça
vous allez ramener le canard et essayer de le
rendre amusant vous les gars prêt pour une
aventure allons y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous sentez l'urine j'adore c'est
comme  parfum officiel de la ville des
choses qui te viennent à l'esprit et qui sortent
de ta bouche
tu t'inquiètes trop c'est pourquoi tes cheveux
sont si beaux as-tu résisté à un homme dans
cet uniforme je ne pense pas que je pourrais t'être
là pour tes frères c'est tout je
remarquez vraiment
que wen  t down terriblement rapide à boire
Fortuna vous avez un vieux et ennuyeux